all right so we have semblance and all
this fine gentlemen I'm talking to right
here what's up Oh your boy all right
so tell me what your involvement is what
semblance well I am the one who writes
nice nice so tell us a little about
semblance what's going on here in this
title all right this is what we're
calling a Plato platform and it's
because you can shape all of a sudden
you need to realize that you've got this
- in mechanic's and because the world is
nice ok cool ok you could say you can
change the world gosh you guys you can
literally change the world so pretty
much you can use the world as part as
part to help you with puzzle mechanics
yeah ok
and I mean if you actually think about
it this is actually the real platform
that is true just been a running jump
when I'm back that is true
linguistically this is this is actually
the right thing it's the actual verb
that platforms are all about that's
where the mechanic realize gotcha
guys so pretty much we're able to
manipulate and get through these puzzles
and kind of thing ok cool cool
now um during this and kind of like does
he also um our main character have like
enemies that he has to go against and
all right so we just using the world
you're just using the world
that was a key part of when we designed
this isn't because one of the games just
be something that you sit down and you
enjoy and this is well it's coming to
Nintendo's switch it's something nice
jump into right where the way you left
the puzzle cool I love that you said
Nintendo so huge
Nintendo switch fan I can totally see
myself on the go you know just trying
some puzzles you know I mean so um yeah
man that's really really really cool you
know as far as like the development how
far along is it you know resembling the
game son push the button we're trying to
get the right button okay we need to
have the right button okay okay yeah now
we're talking also on what other
platforms are besides us which are okay
switch and we are looking into other
oh this absolutely everyone keeps coming
what about what's going on we got to get
there up to this green man okay things
where again you need to think about the
game in a very lab so sense okay still
can't reach it and oh there's another
soft platform so I can just move it out
of the way okay
stop killing my vibe okay I got you now
quick question now with these puzzle
mechanics like you said if you get my
question is if you get stuck like are we
doing like set checkpoints I say I gotta
go let's say I'm stuck at this then you
know got to do a work appointment I want
get back into it are we right back into
the mix with the checkpoints right right
there nice nice because I'm old man I
can't be starting back for the beginning
I'm so glad you guys are forgiving with
that aspect it exactly exactly
things like it's a puzzle gaming you
don't want to be punishing the player
for so not knowing something you talk of
my length you selling me now you said we
wanted it cuz I'll give it played limbo
of course I've never finished it yeah
because it when you mess up and they put
you so far back that's a good point
the way we've designed down no doors
that's just a demo a looping what the
way we've designed it is that we want
players to be able to go to different
puzzles like your brain works in
different ways one puzzle might might
help you figure out how to do the other
one so we don't even get to puzzle and
get stuck gotcha it's just one of those
things where if if your stuff you can
move on and then you can try all the
different slots all and then come back
gotcha that's kind of our ethos between
while the whole game is gotcha you go to
different levels it's not a bad thing
this after this is like here I'm stuck
what do I do
I don't know let me just try something
else oh okay okay I see what you're
saying that is very unique because most
like you said most games will limit you
at that point until you solve said huh
ooh
it won't allow you to even attempt
anything else yes so what you guys are
doing they'll say okay you know what I
can't figure this out right now but hey
I can go do something else come back
catch it the game is not about the
player getting abilities it's by using
the world so the world is is going to be
interesting as you go gachi a player has
everything they need
once they understand a few things like
okay cool we get it now here's the thing
now when you do solve said puzzle is
there any reward so to speak or
progression in reference to said puzzle
that's been solved yes like so the game
is all about collecting essences and
that's what the pink no okay I think oh
that and the whole thing is isn't that
you you're in this world and soft its
cuddly and that's how the whole thing's
been tuned and then there's been some
infection and now that's what the green
stuff so we got a narrative some extra
sauce I thought it was cave painting
okay how's you being able to explore the
world we're also learning about what
happens in precursor to things like
blinking eyes and then you've seen other
little who characters are on the world
they're watching like wait did they get
crystallized you know you're like why
did they get pissed okay and then these
little cave paintings like allude to the
now I love the Cape in do my work just
as it is a puzzle game we wanted to
store do also be a puzzle so it's like
you're going through it you're like oh
this said this they said this you want
to have like a little community around
it being like what really happened what
dodging areas are on so now let's say
this if we happen to discover and it's
figure out all set puzzles yeah does
that picture kind of formulate yes and
we get kind of an idea of what we really
have curing the world okay it's about
curing the world and in fact unless
you're gonna jump to the pre-show that
I'll go for just show you
one that this is a demo loops around
true absolutely let's go play here is
kind of like the way the game is
scenario set up so you can see right now
there we go
sets up everything up god [ __ ] and any
significance behind that word semblance
what I was boiling so you don't keep
that keep that one keyed up keep that
way make sure you buy a nice nice the
character themselves have come from the
world mmm
well you've got eyes at this point oh I
didn't notice that okay gotcha
this is that how the actual games start
gotcha and you kind of and you start
connecting your two abilities so well
that's actually pretty cool as far as
progression is discern yeah digging
tonight and the way we wanted to design
the levels is that the level design
teaches a mechanic it's nothing
oh this is what you do see we just
thought things on the plate you can -
how's your coming here okay no I can't
do that right - then you see the
mechanic got it okay got it
it's almost skill progression as well
the level teaching you you know I'm
saying to help you get acclimated as
well as get through yeah that's the
reform nice you can keep the format as
much as you want and they is so cool
that you actually using the world figure
the plus nice man I'm digging it man
semblance looking good we just need that
release date man it just needs everybody
knows you can't wait to push the button
way to push to play me
very close Neverland all day okay first
baby I love podcast exclusive you heard
it here first not wait man this will be
perfect for me on a switch you know I
don't want to say mindless fun because
there is some mechanics to it you know
say exactly but it definitely is
something where I don't have to stress
too much and I love the fact if I can't
solve a puzzle I come back to it later
appreciative as semblance it allows me
to relax it's like you've collected the
Loon essences and then you bring them
back and you slowly start curing what
and that that goes back to that that pan
semblance link can outwait push the
button push the button absolute pleasure
I love podcast exclusive be in a game
sex life network let's do it man